- Ici, les costumes d'Halloween
côtoient les manteaux d'hiver.
- Oui.- - - - Ça, ça va disparae
bientôt, j'imagine?
- Oui, effectivement.
Pour être remplacé
par les vêtements d'hiver.
- Avec le temps froi
s'installe, la Société Saint-
Vincent de Paul de Montréal
entre dans l'une des périodes
les plus achalandées de l'année.
VALÉRIE HÉLÈNE GAGNON, DG,
Société ViViViVincent de Paul
- On voit une augmentation
de 20 à 30 % de plus de vente.
- Depuis un an, de nouveaux
clients viennent dans cette
friperie. Avec la hausse
ooooût de la vie,
certains tentent d'économiser
comme ils le peuvent.
- C'est sûr que avant c'était
mal vu, mais maintenantc'est pr.
- À la mode, en raison
du taux d'inflation.
L'indice des prix à la
consommation a atteint un sommet
en 40 ans cet été, avant
de connaître un léger recul.
Il s'est établi à 6,9 % au mois
de septetotototoujours bien
au-delà de la cible
de la Banque du Canada.
JURURURURUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On sait très bien que
c'est des mauvaises nouvelles
pour les familles aujourd'hui.
Le coût de la vie, le coût
de l'épicerie, les coûts sont en
train d'augmenter à un moment ùu
les gens sont vraiment inquiets.
(bip)
- C'est effectivement l'épicerie
surtout, qui gonfle l'inflation.
Par rapport à la même période
l'an dernier, le prix de la
viande a augmenté de 7,6 %.
Celui des produits laitiers
de 9,7 %. La boulangerie
de 14,8 %. Tandis que
légumes frais coûtent 11,8 %
plus cher. En moyenne donc,
le prix des aliments a bondi
de 11,4 % en septembre.
Du jamais-vu depuis 1981.
DALIBOR STEVANOVIC, professeur
science économique à l'UQAM
- Maintenant, est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui va durer
ou pas? Les prix des aliments
sont souvent en fonction
des conditions climatiques
dans les endroits où les
aliments sont produits.
- D'ici à ce qu'elles soient
plus abordables, les denrées
à la banque alimentaire de la
Société Saint-Vincent de Paul
continueront de s'envoler
rapidement. Tout comme les
vêtements et les autres produits
dans le magasin adjacent.
- On parle justement d'un
mobilier qu'on va avoir, au lieu
de le payer peut-être
1000, 1500 dollars,
nous o